les américains sont appelés à choisir le
46e président des états unis alors
qu'ils ne donald trump ou joe biden
gagnera cette élection historique
à quelques heures du verdict les
derniers sondages publiés sont toujours
à l' avantage de joe biden mais
souvenez-vous en 2016 donald trump avait
créé la surprise les sondages nationaux
ne sont donc pas forcément de bons
indicateurs pour la présidentielle le
scrutin pourrait être très serré on nous
annonçait une large victoire il a été
une tonne il ya quatre ans j'avais
manier on nous a annoncé depuis des mois
et des mois une large et même très large
victoire de joe biden on sait
aujourd'hui que ce sera sans doute assez
serré et personne n'est capable de dire
quelle sera l'issue du scrutin
cette fois même les états qui peuvent
faire la différence sont quand même en
propension un petit peu plus du côté de
joe biden mais on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'erreurs de ce sondage
selon nicolas bay du rassemblement
national de l'ain trump laisse derrière
lui un bon bilan en revanche pour jean
louis touraine députée est la république
en marche le président sortant a divisé
les états unis donald trump s'était
engagé il ya quatre ans sur un programme
qu'on appelle isolationniste c'est à
dire des états unis qu'ils
n'interviennent pas à tort et à travers
on partout sur la planète et on peut
dire qu'il a honoré ses engagements et
que il ya aussi contribué je crois
plutôt à une pacification des relations
internationales on le voit notamment
avec le bon bilan quel était le sien ce
qui semble de l'amélioration
significative des relations avec la
corée du nord
on peut dire qu'il a un très bon bilan
économique même si évidemment ce bilan a
été ternie par la crise sanitaire
il a réussi à baisser les impôts sur les
entreprises que sur les ménages il a
obtenu pour les etats unis une
croissance record que beaucoup lui
jalousent sur la scène mondiale il a
réussi à faire baisser le chômage dans
toutes les catégories
il a mis en place le protectionnisme sur
lesquels il s'est engagé notamment sur
l'acier et l'aluminium bref il a défendu
les intérêts américains
eric est très largement divisés en
partie en conséquence du mandat de notre
up qui a un peu gênés raid et les
oppositions des radicalisations des uns
contre les autres
entre les différents entre communautés
qui composent la société américaine il
est très clair que l'amérique s'est
davantage encore isolés du reste du
monde et qu'elle a joués l'affrontement
vis-à-vis des autres puissances et non
pas la diplomatie ces quatre dernières
années ont été riches en rebondissements
politiques mais quelles seraient les
conséquences de la réélection de donald
trump ou de l'élection de john dryden
sur l'europe et notamment la france
trump défend les intérêts américains et
quand il met en place des protections
douanières y compris qu'ils peuvent
toucher certains produits français
européen et bien il le fait parce qu'il
considère que ça correspond à ses
intérêts
à nous d'être capable de faire la même
chose chaque fois qu'ils le considèrent
que un affrontement qu'une petite guerre
économique peut lui donne le désavantage
il n'hésitera pas je pense que les
viticulteurs français savent bien le
prix qu'ils ont dû payer je pense que si
drogba y donnait est élu il y aura des
relations plus apaisées
il y aura d'un dialogue et une
diplomatie qui reprendra un petit peu le
cours de ce qu'on a pu connaître si joe
biden gagne donald trump a été clair il
contestera les résultats de l'élection
à la veille du jour j les américains et
le monde entier retiennent leur souffle
les tensions se multiplient aux quatre
coins des états unis laissant craindre
des débordements
al'annonce des résultats